[MUSIC]
Hello and welcome everyone to the
Stanford MBA maximizing the classroom and
academic experience panel.
My name is Lisa John Angela and
I'm a director of MBA admissions as well
as an alumni of the Stanford MBA program.
And I'll be joined today by some of my
fellow alumni who will also share their
experiences about what it's like both
inside and outside the classroom at
the Stanford Graduate School
of Business or Stanford GSB.
Just to know what to expect for
today's session, really our main focus
is to allow you an opportunity
to engage with our community and
to really learn more about the academic
experience at the Stanford GSB.
We'll talk a little bit more about
the resources that are available to you to
build your toolkit.
You'll have an opportunity
to meet our panelists,
I'll start us off with
a little bit of Q&A.
And then really we want to
address your questions.
So at any point in today's session,
if you have a question,
feel free to pop that into the Q&A box.
And our panelists will
try to address that.
If you see a question that someone else
has asked that you particularly like,
feel free to click on that little
thumbs up symbol which will upvote it.
And we'll try to answer as many questions
as we can in the approximate hour that we
have together today.
But let's talk a little bit about all
the resources that are available to you
as you build your toolkit at the GSB,
this is truly a transformative
educational experience.
And one of the things I love about
the GSB is that we use whatever
pedagogy that really optimizes
your learning outcomes.
So it's going to vary class by class and
even within a class,
sometimes week by week.
You're going to be exposed to case
studies and project based courses,
role plays, simulations.
You might actually be
rolling up your sleeves and
building a prototype in one of
your design oriented courses.
You might be participating in
an action based learning program and
partnering with different corporations.
Or you might be in some courses that
are maybe a bit more internal focused and
you're really thinking about your
own personal leadership style.
And getting a lot of really important
leadership coaching and mentoring.
Your first year is predominantly
the core curriculum.
We want to make sure that you're grounded
on all of those general management
disciplines.
But even during your core, you'll see some
different levels based on your experiences
to date, and what you've studied,
and what you've been working in.
Towards the end of your first year, you'll
start taking some elective courses and
your second year is
entirely elective courses,
so if you'd like to go deep in
a particular area, you absolutely can.
But more often than not, we find our
students ramping up their skill sets and
their knowledge in a few different
areas where they have interests.
At the business school, there are a few
different research centers and
learning hubs that you can take advantage
of, so for example, our Center for
Social Innovation or our Center for
Entrepreneurial Studies.
But one of the wonderful things I love
about Stanford GSB is that you're not just
within that business school bubble but
instead you are a part of that entire
Stanford University ecosystem.
And you have access to all seven different
Stanford University graduate schools.
So Stanford is home to some of the top
programs in a number of different fields.
Whether that's law, or medicine, or
education, or engineering, humanities, or
sciences, there are all these
disciplines readily available to you and
we say take advantage of that.
Take classes across the street, as we say,
and approximately 80% of our MBA students
do take classes in other
parts of Stanford University.
And these days about 20% of our MBA
students are actually pursuing a joint or
dual degree during our
time in our MBA program.
So maybe they're doing
another master's program, or
a law degree, or a medical degree, or
something else in addition to their MBA.
And then throughout your time at Stanford,
you're not alone,
there's this whole team of folks who
are there to support you on your journey.
And this ranges from academic, and
career, and student life advisors,
leadership, fellows,
communication coaches.
The faculty, obviously who are here
to help you and support you and
a whole host of general health and mental
health services that are available to you.
But let's hear directly from
some of our panelists and
some of our alumni,
an opportunity to meet them.
I'll have each of our panelists,
if you wouldn't mind,
briefly introducing yourselves.
We'll go in the order that we
see here on the screen, so
Diego if you'd like to start us off.
>> Welcome my name is De Antonella,
I'm from Lima Peru,
I was at the GSB between 2016 and 18.
During that time I incubated
a social enterprise called
Latin American Leadership Academy, which
I have been running full time ever since
through epidemic,
which has been a lot of fun.
So happy to answer questions around,
the social impact,
the social innovation,
the entrepreneurship side of the GSB.
How the professors,
the alumni community have been
instrumental in my journey and more.
Great to meet you all.
>> I think that makes me next.
I'm Ilana, I was GSB class of 2020, and
I am now talking at you from Houston Texas
where I'm a consultant for Dane.
Before that I grew up in Portland, Oregon.
Went to a tiny college called
the Olin College of Engineering.
And by tiny, I mean,
80 people a year, truly tiny.
And everyone was an engineer.
Ran away from engineering, did a masters
in England, in European literature.
And then a fulbright year also focused
on literature and theater in Germany,
I followed that up with working as
a product manager in tech for Yahoo,
and then came to the GSB.
And who knows where I'm going next?
But I had a great time taking advantage of
all the things that GSB had to offer, so
looking forward to
talking to you about it.
>> Hi everyone my name is Jorge,
I'm GSB class of 2020, and
I'm originally from Peru also from Lima.
But I grew up in Orange County
in Southern California where
I am right now visiting my family.
And I currently live full time in
San Francisco, so close by to the GSB.
I did my undergrad at Stanford where I
studied computer science and economics for
undergrad.
Then I did a computer science
master's degree also at Stanford.
And then actually during my CS masters,
I worked on an interdisciplinary
class in the school of engineering with
a couple of students from the GSB.
And actually that's one of the big factors
that motivated me to apply to the GSB
program, so I did.
Both of my graduate
degrees at Stanford but
not through the dual program because I
applied while I was doing the CS masters.
But I just really enjoyed the perspective
that the GSB students brought in terms of
their business knowledge as well
as their interpersonal skills.
So I wanted to learn the same skills they
seemed to have gained at the GSB, and
that's what motivated me to apply and
have a background in tech.
I work as a product manager, and
I'm particularly interested in emerging
technologies like artificial
intelligence and blockchain crypto.
>> Hi, everyone, I'm Josh,
I graduated about three weeks
ago from the Stanford GSB.
As an undergrad,
I was a bioengineering major with plans to
become this physician scientist, MD, PhD,
professor, I quickly realized that maybe
that wasn't exactly what I wanted to do.
And so I took a leave from the MD PhD
program at Johns Hopkins to launch
my first startup,
a kidney disease diagnostics
company as a technical co founder.
But I quickly realized that I actually
wanted to be on the business side
of things.
And so that's why I knew that I had this
chance to Stanford GSB so I could learn
the business skills and build a network
necessary to make those dreams come true.
And so now that I've graduated,
I am the co-founder and
CEO of Blink Biotechnologies, which is
a biotech startup based here in San
Francisco, where I'm currently located.
>> Hi everyone, great to be here.
I'm Sebastian.
I'm from Mexico City.
That's where I am now.
I graduated from the GSB in 2017.
I did a dual degree with
the Kennedy School at Harvard University,
which is School of Government at Harvard,
where I studied a master's in economics
and international development.
Before that grad school stand tight,
I actually worked for my undergraduate
institution for Yale, hoping to
invest in the university's endowment,
things kind around natural resources and
energy.
And now I do that in Mexico and
Latin America,
doing investments in decarbonization and
renewable energy, basically.
So happy to talk about what
it's like to do a dual degree,
especially when you're
not in the same location,
and moving across places, or anything
else that you guys want to talk about.
>> Great, well, thank you.
I'll start us off with a few questions
before we go to our audience questions.
So again, our audience,
if you have anything on your mind,
please feel free to go to that Q&A box and
type some questions in.
But a general question for
all of our panelists here,
what was one of your favorite classes or
academic experiences, and why?
>> My favorite class of the GSB was
reputation management by Allison Kluger,
which is a class where you
actually ask your classmates and
other people that are important to you
in your life how they view you, and
what their perception of you is.
And it was one of the best ways for
me to get feedback about how
I show up in the world, and
how I could decide to change or
not change different aspects of myself.
And so I gained so much from that class.
And it was a really good experiential
class in which you really went out and
sought feedback on how
to improve yourself.
>> This is hard, because I have five, and
I was really hoping that other people
would go first and say some of them,
so that I could say whichever
one hadn't been covered.
But if I have to pick one, I'm going to
pick dynamics of the global wine industry,
which is taught by Alyssa Rapp.
It is a great class, so great,
that I essentially took it twice,
once as a student, and once as a TA.
And it's not just because you taste
a lot of really great wine in class.
Although you do, and
that's definitely a benefit.
But I also think that that
class was actually the best
strategy class I took at the GSB.
We have a lot of foundation
strategy classes,
which should give you a lot of
frameworks which are useful.
But this really applied it all to
an industry that is really difficult to
navigate, right, global, highly regulated.
It deals with kind of all of the problems
you could imagine an industry has to
deal with.
And learning from people, and
really brainstorming ways to build
successful businesses in spite of that
was a really great education for me.
Also, Alyssa Rapp is an amazing human
being, and well worth taking a class with,
just to get to meet her.
>> All right, this next one, Sebastian,
I'll have you start us off here.
We talked about how the Stanford GSB
utilizes a variety of teaching methods,
ranging from case to role plays,
simulations,
all sorts of different things here.
How do you think that enhanced your
learning experience during your time at
Stanford?
>> Sure, no, I think as I was reflecting
for the seminar, I was really thinking of
the exact point that you're making on
the diversity of classes that you take on.
So when I think of the types of classes,
I took a class that's kind of GSB,
and part of the design code school
called design for extreme affordability,
where we were literally using our hands to
build a fertilizer for farmers in Africa.
We took a very hardcore finance class
that feels very much as you're in
a lecture listening to a hugely successful
professor on financial economic theory,
and probably not understanding 50% of what
is happening, but you're in that lecture.
And then you also have classes that
are really about kind of role playing,
and putting yourself in a practicing mode,
things that now in my career,
I really value now.
Also, I took a class, for example,
called Managing Difficult Conversations
with with Eric Groesbeck,
who's probably one of the kind of most
famous professors at the GSB, and
you're practicing firing people.
And so now [LAUGH] in my job,
I had never fired someone before, and
I had to recently fire someone.
And I was immediately
thinking of the practice I at
least had doing that once at the GSB.
And then you also have classes
like startup garage, and
these kinds of classes where you're
literally kind of building your business,
and have an incredible amount of
resources to build that business.
So my wife also went to the GSB, and she
now has a startup that she started at in
this class, startup garage, and was able
to spend six months during her second
year getting credit for
building that class.
And so in addition to having that
diversity of literally every kind of type
of education you can imagine,
I also think that diversity actually
translates to very real life
valuable experience post-GSB.
And that kind of diversity has been,
at least for me,
really critical in my
career post-Stanford.
So hopefully that answered your questions.
>> Absolutely, this next question all
point towards Alana, Diego, and Josh.
What was your relationship
like with faculty?
How did you interact with them in or
out of the class in different ways?
Alana, maybe if you'd
like to start us off?
>> Sure, well, you take a lot
of classes at once at the GSB.
So the reality is you're not going to be
best friends with every single faculty
member.
But I did definitely take time outside of
class to get to know particular faculty
members when I loved their class, or where
I felt a strong connection with them.
And that looked like going to office hours
sometimes, but it also just looked like
asking them to take some random time with
me, and I've never had anyone say no.
And usually,
they just desperately want to help you.
One reason I really love Alyssa Rapp
is I showed up to this one on one
that I had asked her to have with me.
She sat down, and she said okay, what do
you want to do during your internship?
What do you want to do post-GSB?
And I said well, I want to explore
working for a performing arts nonprofit.
I'm really hoping to get
an internship there.
She went great, here are four leaders
of performing arts nonprofits but
I have personal connections to.
Which ones would you like
email introductions to?
And that was actually how I got my summer
internship at a major ballet company,
absolutely no relation to
what she was teaching.
I'd expected we were going to
talk wine in her class.
But what she really just wanted was
to be useful to me as a student.
And I found that across
the professors that I connected with.
And I really loved getting
to know them better, and
having them wanting to marshal
their resources to help me.
That's a hugely valuable asset
while you're at the GSB.
>> Diego, how about your experience
interacting with faculty?
>> How fantastic [LAUGH].
So I remember in my interview,
I was told that one of the most
underutilized assets of
the GSB are the professors.
And I kind of blew it off
as a marketing stunt.
And At the GSB and
then especially post GSB,
I'm blown away by the caliber
of the professors.
They truly are leaders in their
industries and amazing people.
So some GSB professors
have been unofficial and
official advisors for Laila,
the social enterprise I founded.
Some have been donors,
I'm not going to tell you whom,
some helped us find our main donors.
Some helped us get foundation support
in the foundation that they worked at.
Yeah, they've been amazing.
And also know in hindsight,
Lisa, that, for example,
we're trying to find certain funders or
to get to work with some foundations.
I'm like, it's so
hard to get to Eric Schmidt now.
It would have been nicer
to take his class, or
I would have been nicer to take the class
with say the CEO of Omidyar Network.
Now, it's really hard
that I'm on the outside.
So definitely wonderful professors and
great opportunity to get to
meet them while you're a student
at the GSB outside of class.
>> Josh, how about your experience
as of interacting with faculty?
>> Yeah, I've had amazing experiences with
faculty both sort of in the classroom
setting related to the academics, as well
as outside related to my startup, and
entrepreneurial endeavors.
And I served as a TA for multiple faculty.
I did a independent study with a faculty
member on kidney disease in the US and
healthcare system, where I was able
to work with five other my fellow
classmates on this
independent study project.
Really dive deep into one area of
healthcare that I was really passionate
about.
And having supportive faculty through
as into the academic project was
really valuable in terms of
getting access to people who had
information that maybe I would not
have been able to talk to, otherwise.
And even for my entrepreneurial endeavors,
I have to say that the faculty of the GSB
both are just so kind and willing to help,
but also so well-connected and
successful in their own right.
And so what, some one of the faculty
members is an investor in my company now.
One of them I use as a reference check for
my investors who were
considering investing.
And that investor told
me that they were so
impressed that this faculty members that
such good things about me that that was
a one of the reasons that they
decided to invest, actually.
And another faculty was actually knew one
of my potential board members and was able
to provide me with deep insight into how
this person operated as a board member.
And so truly, I think the resources and
the value you can get from
the faculty relationships.
I think this runs the entire
gamut of all possible things.
And so, I've had a really great experience
getting to know the faculty I've
taken the classes with and even those
ones I haven't even taking classes with.
>> Great, the specs questions.
>> If there's just one thing I would add
just for more of a social dynamic with
professors, these my housemates and I,
our second year people, live in houses.
And so, we did this, but
a lot of people do this every Wednesday.
We would invite a different professor
to come have dinner with us and
they'd spend three to five hours with
us having dinner, drinking wine,
talking about academic things,
talking about their lives.
And I was just always so blown away by the
willingness of people to just kind of do
that and engage with you and
in a more social setting.
Now, in addition to the points,
so I, Johnston, and
David brought up a bit more academic.
This was just a purely
social experience that was wonderful
>> Wonderful.
I've heard many of those stories too.
Some of the top US economic advisors who
are faculty are off mountain biking during
the weekend with students and things,
I think they're just wonderful connections
that are made during your time there.
And Jorge, this next question,
we'll have you start us off here.
What are some ways that students can help
shape the academic experience, either for
themselves or through others?
>> Yeah, there's so many different
ways that you can get involved with
shaping the academic experience.
One of the big ways that I participated
in during my time at Stanford GSB was as
a member of the academic committee, which
is a part of the GSB student government
that focuses on shaping
the academics experience.
Serving as a liaison between
the students and the faculty, and
that included things like collecting
feedback from students about the different
classes, especially with
a focus on first years.
Making sure that people feel like they're
being supported in the first quarter as
they're transitioning into the GSB to make
sure they have the tutoring support that
they need for
some of the more difficult classes.
To make sure that professors are providing
a type of curriculum that engages
students and resonates with students both
in terms of the material with regards
to the companies being discussed.
As well as the diversity of the content
focusing on female founders,
minority entrepreneurs,
that type of thing to make sure that
the content appeals to a broad range
of students from all backgrounds.
In addition to that, I worked on
organizing our quarterly academic small
group dinners, which connected small
groups of students with a faculty member.
And we provided funding for that for
students to get reimbursed for
either going out to dinner or ordering
dinner to be at the dorms that are at
their house with different faculties.
So this is a great opportunity for
students to connect with particular
faculty members, whether it's from
their existing classes, or people who
they actually haven't taken the class
as up-to-date want to learn more about.
And this is a great opportunity to build
those more personal relations with faculty
because sometimes they'll be willing
to share some more personal aspects of
their life or
their background that you might not get
to hear about within the classroom.
And for me, actually,
some of those dinners helped me learn
about professors in a way that like.
I guess when I took their class maybe
I didn't expect I would connect with
them on such a personal level, but
speaking to them during dinner.
I found that we had a lot in common and
then their professors that I've maintained
contact with, and
I'm close with in the long term.
And then, another great way to
get involved is connecting your
experience with the different student
groups, to your academic experience, and
that's something I did.
I was one of the co-founders of
the Stanford Blockchain Club,
which is an undergraduate and
graduate interest group for
people who are interested in
blockchain and cryptocurrencies.
And there's a couple of professors
who were starting crypto and
blockchain classes my year,
and they didn't have that much technical
or academic experience in the space.
But from my computer science engineering
degree, I had worked with Dan Boney,
who's one of the top
researchers in the field.
So I helped make a lot of the connections,
both to academics in the field as well as
to entrepreneurs working in
the blockchain space to get speakers.
And to figure out case studies for the
various classes, as well as to host small
group events to connect students to
the speakers that came to visit in a more
intimate setting after we have these
classes with the guests that we invited.
And then, through my experience as
a first-generation and low-income student,
I also founded the First Gen
Low Income Stanford GSB Club.
And through this club, I help to advocate
for providing more resources and
opportunities for
students who come from this background.
Who were the first to go to college from
their families who may need additional
financial support because they have a lot
of financial stresses from the families
back home.
And in this way, for
example, we advocated for
additional tutoring sessions maybe for
students who came from different academic
backgrounds to make sure that they were
supported as they started the GSB.
As well as additional ways to
provide financial support,
especially to students who
maybe have families or
other dependents that
they're supporting as well.
So basically like.
The GSB provides so many opportunities for
you to take the initiative and
shape your experience.
And the experience of your peers
in whatever way you want, and
I actually just thought of
two other really cool ways.
But in my GSB experience,
I also helped to lead the Stanford AI
salon which was a speaker series.
That brings in speakers from
the artificial intelligence field.
And that was a great way to connect
artificial intelligence from
a technical standpoint.
To the social impact that that
has across the world, and
in terms of economics, social issues.
And then also through that I helped
to advise the FDA on their policies
around regulating artificial
intelligence in a medical context.
So that was also experience
related to academics.
>> Nice, nice, I want to build
off something that Jorge said.
Kind of in how you were talking
about the block chain course,
the AI kind of interactions.
We talked about how Stanford,
GSB is part of that much larger
ecosystem at Stanford University.
So maybe Alana and Sebastian,
if you want to tackle this question.
Did you take advantage of classes or
learning opportunities outside
the business school or elsewhere?
And tell us a little bit more about that,
Alana, do you want to start?
>> Well, yes, I took quite if
you across the street classes,
which is what we call GSB years
taking classes outside of the GSB.
One was business related and
really to supplement my GSB education.
And that was the negotiation
class at Stanford Law School.
The GSB also has a negotiation class
the law school, one is hot and
a little bit of different format and
style.
So I thought it would suit me better and
it was a wonderful class,
I was very happy with it.
And then I took a bunch of across
the street classes just for fun,
to get a change from
the business school curriculum.
So I took some pretty obscure like Spanish
and Portuguese pastoral literature.
And many people retellings
about particular myth.
And it was really just to meet
other Stanford people, and
get my head out of the business space.
And into something that's already been,
always been really fun for me.
>> Great, and Sebastian,
you want to talk about your experiences
outside of the business school?
>> Yeah, sure, so right,
I took several classes outside of school,
so outside of the business school within
Stanford that I won't elaborate on.
But I think one of the big experiences for
me was combining the MBA curriculum and
this other degree at Harvard,
focused on economics etc.
And so
I think that was challenging for sure,
because you're moving across
the country [LAUGH] three times.
You need to miss out on certain things,
because there's a quarter when you need to
be at the Kennedy School and vice versa.
But beyond those kind of
logistical issues,
I think it really enhanced
the academic experience I had.
I was able to take a lot of insights and
things that I was maybe thinking from
a top public policy
perspective at Kennedy school.
And then bring them back and
think about them more from
the business school perspective.
I had professors who knew
each other at both schools.
And that really created kind of a unique
way to interact with each of them,
and actually jointly on a few things.
So I think that for me,
that just really enhanced the experience.
And in addition,
it was just incredible to see the support
that you get from the GSB to be
able to do those kinds of things.
And I think evidence of that is that now
one in five I think is what Lisa said,
of students do some sort of dual degree.
Or for joint degree comm, so
it's become kind of a part of
the community that is very normal,
very supportive.
And for me, personally very
enhancing to my education, so
I really grateful I did it.
>> Great.
>> Building on that,
I think one of the things that I liked
the most about the GSB experiences.
Both the flexibility of the academic
experience to tailor it
to exactly what you need and
want out of your experience.
As well as the close integration between
the GSB and these other schools.
With regards to the flexibility,
one of the cool things is that
basically after your first quarter.
You always have some room in your schedule
to be able to fit in any classes you want
from any other part of Stanford.
And the nice thing about it is that
you're not restricted by like,
you can only take a certain
number of classes.
You can basically fit in as many across
the street classes as you can fit within
your maximum units that
you're allotted for Stanford.
So you can essentially take
as many classes as you want,
as long as your meeting all
of your GSP requirements.
And as long as you're within
the maximum allowed, and
I definitely took advantage of that.
I took classes, even more classes
in the computer science department.
Because there's just so
many cool classes which engineering.
And some classes in law school,
which was really cool because I had never
done anything related to law before.
And that gave me a strong background for
the work I was doing, advising the FDA.
And then also, I got to explore some
new interests, I took a sailing class.
There's a bay area near
Stanford in Redwood City, and
they have a sailing club there.
So I got to go there a couple of times
each week to go and learn how to sail,
it's just really cool.
And then I also took an electronic
music production class.
Which was a really cool way to connect my
interest in the arts with my experience in
technology.
And that was through karma which
was the Stanford Center for
music and for the arts.
>> I see, go ahead Alana.
>> I just want to say one quick thing
which is that I know this an academics
panel, but it's not just classes.
One of the things that was really fun, and
I think is underutilized by GSB students.
Is the ability to get involved
with student organizations that
are Stanford wide.
>> Absolutely.
I think Nate is had a chance to join us,
would you like to briefly
introduce yourself?
Welcome.
>> Yeah, hi everyone, apologies for
joining tremendously late
coming from something else.
A class of 16, I came to GSB having
worked for 6 years in corporate finance.
And then after GSB,
I spent 4 years in consulting and
now I'm in the venture world in a hybrid
role, but mostly a platform role.
So working with our LPs and our portfolio
companies within the FinTech and
banking space to connect.
And yeah, I just really love Stanford and
opened a lot of doors for me,
and I was excited to join today.
So I'm really sad I missed the first
portion but happy to meet you.
>> Nice we'll catch you out up,
maybe you could share with us
one of your favorite classes.
Or academic experiences
during your time at Stanford.
>> Yeah, I'll share my favorite GSB class
and then my favorite Stanford class.
So my favorite GSB class was
high performance leadership.
I think it's what it's called,
I like to describe it as touchy
feely to or applied touchy feely.
I really took a lot from that class that
when I was managing
people as a consultant.
Came to play both with our clients and
coaching them, but also my own team.
And then outside the GSB I took,
I forgot the exact name of it,
but it was an economics theory class.
And it was, I didn't intend to sign up for
a PhD class, but I'm really glad I did.
Because we just talked
about things that were so
out of the norm of what I would
have otherwise had exposure to.
That I think, opened the door for
me to understand certain things in
business differently and- I think it
was like economic theory of
institutions or something like that.
And scrape rate class so backhoe,
the take classes outside your
comfort zone across the street.
>> Yeah, that actually reminds me
of that this other class I took,
I took a quantum computing class without
any background in quantum computing or
quantum mechanics or physics or anything.
And I definitely didn't expect it to be
what was essentially like my favorite
class ever, but just the way that
the class was integrated with technology,
physics, math, and even philosophy.
Like learning about quantum computing
helped me think about the world and
how people are connected and
all of the possibilities that could exist
with different universes and everything.
And it was a very deep experience way
beyond anything that I had expected
before I decided to take it.
>> Great, I want to build off one of the
classes I just heard mentioned a minute
ago and we affectionately refer
to it as touchy feely, but
its real name is interpersonal dynamics.
And I noticed in the q&a section
folks were asking about classes like
interpersonal dynamics or
other great soft skills courses, so
does anyone want to quickly describe
what interpersonal dynamics is?
And then also maybe mentioned some of your
other favorite soft skills courses like
high performance leadership
with triad as well.
>> I can take that since
I brought it [LAUGH].
I presume it's still the same since
a few years ago but essentially.
I would say there's really two overarching
things you get out of the class,
with a lot of nuance sub
points you can get out of it.
So the first major thing is,
how do you people experience you?
Like how do you show up to people?
And then the second is like,
what assumptions do you make
about people as you're
interacting with them that May
influence your behavior for
good, bad, indifferent.
And the way the class is structured
is you're in a group of about 12.
And there's a plenary component each week
and then you spend 4 or 5 hours in a room.
If you're 12 people with
a very loose agenda, and
it's awkward, and then stuff happens.
And then you all learn and
to be really honest with each other, and
there's two facilitators and so for
someone who's hyper structured,
you're just like you want me to do what?
And then eventually you kind
of just see that the group
naturally starts to create learning for
each other.
And then at the end of the class,
there's a weekend or
a couple days where you do really
just that, but like for eight or
12 hours at a time, and
then you do a lot of reflection and
a lot of writing and
I think it's a really great course.
If that's a focus of yours.
And then one other class that
I would add in the soft skills
area is it was a communications class.
I don't remember the name of it, but
really, you're just learning how
to communicate and you have to do a lot
of presentation, a lot of different
exercises and I think It sounds
like it should be straightforward.
But it, you actually take a lot out of
it if communication is something you
want to work on.
And I believe the instructor
I can't remember her name but
is someone who's very well known
in the communication coaching
world has been working with
Stanford students for a long time.
And I just found her What she
picked up about the nuances,
not just your verbal,
your oral communication but
your non-verbal communication
to be really helpful.
>> We have a great question from
an audience member here of,
how would you describe the learning
culture and environment at the GSB?
Let's describe the learning culture and
environment.
>> I can go I think one of the things that
really appeals to me about the GSB is just
a collaborative culture.
I think like.
It's not cutthroat at all.
It's not like me against you buying for
professors time or for resources.
It's like me and you working together
to uplift both of us uplift everyone,
like what can I do to help you
to improve your experience?
I think it's all about growing, and
learning together as an entire class, and
as an entire GSB community, and that's
one of the things that I love the most.
I've always felt really supported
in terms of like emotional support,
community support, it just feels
like a family in a lot of ways.
>> Yeah, I would just add to
that point I've already made and
people who have graduated more recently.
I don't know if there's a change but that
there is a great non disclosure policy,
which which invites what quarter has
said in a very obvious way, right?
No one is kind of competing when
going to a potential employer,
whatever to say,
I got this great or that great.
And so that creates a very kind of
collaborative culture as what we're
saying.
The only other thing I would say
about I think a culture that I,
as I reflect on both my experiences,
both at Harvard and Stanford.
I think the goal that Stanford has of
having all these kind of soft skill
classes like interpersonal dynamics
that Nadia was describing,
create a dynamic where people are
constantly asking each other for feedback.
Constantly role playing things,
and really trying to just improve
themselves as human beings that I have
never seen in another environment and
so that actually becomes a really cool
culture where it's encouraged to reflect,
to give each other feedback,
to be honest with each other.
That I think was really unique
at least in what I've seen.
So, I really enjoyed that as well.
>> We have another question here of, could
you elaborate on the extent of teamwork
and leadership opportunities
within the classes you took?
>> I can go for that.
So there's actually so
many classes as people have already
mentioned that startup garage.
There's also across the street classes
that bring in students from all
the different Stanford schools.
To work together.
So you could work hands-on on
various different projects.
Like I took an entrepreneurship class in
which we were designing a business and
I was working with people across GSB,
law school, engineering school and
we essentially like came
up with a business plan.
Came up with the financial Statements
created a presentation for
pitch that we did to actual venture
capitalists from Sandhill road,
who gave us feedback on our pitch.
And in each of these experiences,
the cool thing is that there's many
opportunities for you to take the lead.
And figure out the dynamic with
the team that you're working on.
So maybe in some cases, you'll
actually want to be the one that takes
the lead on something and
you'll gain like leading experience there.
But also in some cases, actually what's
better for the team as a whole is for
you to take a step back and
to be a follower or
to be a supporting team member rather than
the leader in that particular instance.
So I think that's one of the really cool
learning experiences is that you learn
that leadership It doesn't just
mean being the one at the top,
who is managing everything,
and telling people what to do.
Leadership means doing
whatever is necessary,
to make sure that your team is successful.
And that can mean working in a large
variety of roles, which sometimes aren't
the one that's out in the front
having that very visible role.
And it can mean being a supporter or
someone who is providing a foundation for
the other team members
to do their best work.
And you're able to learn about those
dynamics and see how you can fit in most
effectively in different situations
through the project based classes.
>> Here's a question that was
directed towards Sebastian but
I think anyone is also
welcome to chime in here.
Which classes and or experiential learning
experiences were the most useful for
you to really become
a leader in your career.
>> I think a couple come to mind.
One is touchy freely, or
sorry, interpersonal dynamics.
Because I think that gives
you a lot of feedback,
as Mindy was saying, on how you come
across and what is the impact that certain
things that you hadn't even thought of or
having on others.
And so it's a very unique
setting in that front and
that's helped me at least measure
more carefully how I have
certain interactions from
a professional standpoint.
The other one is the one
I alluded to earlier
the managing difficult conversations.
Which was one where you're basically
role-playing difficult conversations,
firing someone,
having a big discussion with the partner
about how you should split equity.
Those kinds of things that are at
a theoretical level, very easy to do, but
once you're actually doing
a role-playing exercise,
it at least gives you one to have done
that before you're actually doing it live.
And so I think those two for
me at these were
have been very valuable in my career.
>> Something I've had to add that struck
me from my time at the GSB is that.
Sometimes you hear this idea of, did you
really have to go to the GSB to learn
about marketing because we
could have bought that book.
Same for finance or accounting,
same for a lot of things.
One thing that I really valued was
that you have this combination
of industry leaders.
And world class researchers who have
curated all of these resources and
what I found very impactful was
how consistent the narrative,
the values, the worldviews the mind sets,
war and leaves.
I don't know if this is intentional or
no but
pretty much everywhere at
the GSB I heard this idea of like.
Hey you know to be a better leader you
should listen to be a better leader you
should really care for the other person.
You should be kind you should live
by your values you should this
you should that sorry.
I think there's only one class that offers
kind of like the dark side narrative which
is has to power.
I didn't take it, but
I might have something is that this
professor's narrative is, yeah,
all of that is beautiful but you should
not ignore how power works in the world.
So this class is focused on power but
everything else was is very consistent
story like even like how to fire people,
negotiations and so on.
Everything was very consistent
around like age, be a good person.
Just bring your best and actually
there's hard evidence that supports it.
This will help you be a better leader,
a better negotiator, better salesperson,
better boss and so on.
And that helped me just cut through
all the noise of so many gurus and
books out in the world and
I was like, okay, amazing.
I can be myself I can be
trying to be a good person.
And I can also be a better leader,
a better entrepreneur in doing so.
And I have a consistent theoretical
base and evidence base behind this and
I found that super helpful.
>> There's a lot on empathetic leadership
for sure that I that I've heard yeah.
Here's another question from the audience
of how did you balance your academic
schedule with all the other
opportunities available at the GSB?
And what is the typical week in
the life of a student look like?
Fiona smiling,
do you want to take that one?
[LAUGH]
>> I'm laughing because when I went
into consulting which is famously
long hours profession but
I definitely have more free
time now than I did at the GSB.
Just because I scheduled everything so
tightly at the GSB right.
It wasn't that I was doing academics for
60 hours a week.
But I was doing something from
8AM to midnight every day, and
it's just a calendar management game.
You quickly decide how much effort
you want to put into academics and
people vary a ton on that, right?
You want to put in absolutely enough to
get value out of your classes, but you can
push very far past that or you can do
the bare minimum to be learning something.
And so that determines how many hours
you need to devote to academics.
And the rest of it will fill up with
everything from coffee chats with
people to club events to phone,
which is our Tuesday night parties.
And as long as you keep a good calendar,
it's incredible how much
you can fit into a week.
I think to add on to that,
the framework that I often give people
is first start with like,
what are you doing all of this for?
Like if you have to pick three to five
priorities that you're going to use for
as a decision rubric for
how you spend your time.
What are you doing all of this for?
And having clarity on that, I think makes
everything else much easier because
then you can say, okay, this quarter
this month, this week this day,
I have 20 options,
which of those serve that purpose?
And then how am I going
to mix them together to.
Make this all work and
the reality is like,
if you don't use calendars you're
going to have a rough two years.
[LAUGH] And I think that you have to
decide where do you need to double
down and spend time,
I took classes where I learned a lot.
But I didn't necessarily spend a lot of
hours either because of my background or
because the content was structured
such that I didn't have to do a lot of
stuff outside class based
done the course itself.
And so you can kind of mix and
match those, right?
Like it may not be a good idea in
the quarter that you're trying to plan
a conference, and also recruit,
to take a bunch of classes that require
you to do four hours of case reading and
writing before each class.
So you Kind of just figure that out for
yourself.
And the last thing I would say is think
about kind of how things build on each
other as you're determining your
courses and in other our experiences.
So for example, I wanted to take
certain classes before I went and
did my internship abroad.
Because I wanted to take some
of those perspectives and
go see what it looked like
when I was like on the ground.
And so those are some subtle things
I would also just add to think about.
>> I see a question here touching concrete
disclusure that was brought briefly
before and how it aid to that
clubitive culture and learning by but
this question really
another that talk about.
How does that actually push you
to take some academic risks and
to try some classes that might be really
hard and outside of your comfort zone?
Can any of you share an example where
maybe you took a class that was a little
bit scary or intimidating or
outside your comfort zone?
>> I was really scared to take financial
trading strategies which ended
up being one of my favorite classes.
Because it's a class where you spend
a bunch of your time in class and a large
portion of your grade is determined by
how you do in these market simulations.
Where you are trading stocks or
options or whatever the topic of that
class period is, in real time in a sort
of compressed simulation of the market.
And I came to the GSB from
zero finance background.
I had really only taken my required first
year in GSB finance courses before this.
So it was kind of a leap of
faith to take that class but
it ended up being one of the coolest
classes I took, because it really taught
me how the market actually works and
what options really are and
what they mean and how people trade
them beyond the academic side of it.
But I had learned in my
foundation finance class.
>> I think I have a similar story to Ilana
where I also have no finance coming into
the GSB.
In fact, at one of these admin receptions,
I met a fellow classmate who told me they
were in PE and I asked her if she was in
physical education because I had no
idea that private equity was a job.
And I ended up taking like over seven
different finance classes at the GSB.
Most of them I took pass fail in the end.
So corporate financial modeling,
the financial restructuring debt class.
These are all things that have
absolutely zero background in and
I think because of great on disclosure and
generous pass fail policies at the GSB.
I was able to take these classes that I
was interested in knowing that I had no
background in them but wanted to learn
more about it and was able to now having
graduated have a decent amount of
finance knowledge relative to before.
>> This next question maybe
Diego I'll have you kick us off here.
But what advice would you have for
incoming MBA students who are really
trying to maximize their
academic experience and
their their classroom
experience at the GSB?
What advice would you give people?
I'll take the focus advice.
If someone else has the go explore advice,
go for it.
[LAUGH] But
I came in laser focused, right.
My essay was about Lola,
it talked about, like by name,
this is the thing I want to build.
So that helped me cut through
a lot of that noise, there's so
many opportunities that you could take.
It helped me say no to a lot of things.
Really focus on what classes
to take every single project
in every single class somehow was
geared towards this organization.
A lot of classmates used me and
Lola to dip their toes into social
entrepreneurship, into sub garage,
and so on.
So that was beautiful.
Many of the relationships that I
ended up building with professors,
with staff from the Center for
Social Innovation, with classmates
have all been hugely valuable
>> And
the others want to share advice on how
to maximize your academic experience.
>> I think you should,
I came in with not one thing but
like three things that I was really
gearing my academics around.
One was developing economies the other
was, interpersonal development/leadership.
And then the third one was strategy.
And so I think for me as I thought
about what classes to take,
they had to revolve around that.
And you'll notice I didn't say
entrepreneurship anywhere in
there which confuses people because
I managed to get out of the GSB,
taking only one entrepreneurship
[LAUGH] managing growing enterprises.
And I think that like a healthy
amount of curiosity is important but
that looks different for everyone and
my biggest piece of advice is like,
don't try to replicate
what alumnus did and
don't try to replicate what
your classmates are doing.
Because even if you do exactly what they
did, you'll come out with a completely
different experience anyway, so you
might as well live your own experience.
And I think that just
takes some courage to be,
this is what I think I want to do and
whatever that looks just go with it and
the luxury is every quarter you
can kind of change your mind.
But you only get six of them.
So, yeah, make use of them.
And so that's how I think about it.
>> Great advice.
Well, I want to be cognizant of my time.
So I want to thank all of our panelists
today for sharing your perspectives.
I also hope that this is just the start
of our attendees MBA journey.
And one way to continue that
is through my stanford.mba.
If you haven't already been to the site,
definitely check it out.
You can create your own
personalized dashboard.
That'll tee up classes or clubs that
might be of interest to you students or
alumni profiles that you might relate to.
If you start the application, you can
also track your progress through that and
learn about other great events like today.
So again, thank you so
much for joining us.
We really appreciate it and best of
luck on your MBA journey, thank you
[MUSIC]